welcome to the 2018 silliman Memorial
Lecture my name is J Humphrey and I am a
faculty member here and biomedical
engineering and it's really my pleasure
and honor to introduce our colleague
from Rice University Department by
medical a bio engineering before I
invite her to the podium however I'd
like to call your attention to the brief
description of this lecture that can be
found in the back of your program
establish near the turn of the 20th
century this lecture honors
mrs. HEPA silliman daughter of a 1769
Yale graduate and mother of an 1824 Yale
graduate today we continue this legacy
of remembrance the first Solman lecture
was delivered in 1901 by JJ Thompson
discoverer of electron in addition to
his many contributions to science he was
also well known as a gifted teacher and
mentor indeed many who worked with him
also went on to earn Nobel prizes as one
reviews the history of this venerable
lecture many other names from physics
chemistry mathematics medicine medicine
and beyond can be found as for example
rough Rutherford Nernst Arrhenius Osler
Hadamard Bohr Hubbell Leakey and others
today we're honored to continue continue
this tradition for which we have a
legacy of over a century and with us
today is someone who is similarly
committed to discovery as well as
engineering science and design in the
translation of new knowledge to improve
the human condition
she is also as was the inaugural
silliman lecturer a committed teacher
and mentor truly an outstanding role
model in every regard
Rebecca Richards quartum is the Malcolm
Gillis University professor of
bioengineering Electrical and Computer
Engineering at Rice University and
director of the rice 360 Institute for
global health
and founder of beyond traditional
borders she has contributed fundamental
and translational findings in by medical
optics and global health among other
areas her work has been published in
over 315 archival journal articles and
she is author of a book published by
Cambridge University Press by medical
engineering for global health these
works have been cited nearly 28,000
times I refer you to the center portion
of the program for more information but
briefly professor Richards quartum has
received many well-deserved honors
including being named Howard Hughes
Medical Institute professor a MacArthur
Fellow she is an elected member of the
National Academy of Engineering and also
the National Academy of Science she is a
member of the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences in the American
Philosophical Society among others most
importantly however professor Richards
quartum cares deeply about people and
she has dedicated her professional life
to creating new technologies to provide
improved health care to vulnerable
populations especially those in remote
or low resource settings since this
lecture is being taped I now ask that
you would kindly silence your cell phone
or other electronic devices as you join
me in welcoming professor Rebecca
Richards quartum
[Applause]
to be here today and to have the
opportunity to share our work with you
thank you so much for the invitation
it's been a really exciting and
inspiring day and I am really looking
forward to talking with you about my
favorite thing in the world which is
babies and I'm gonna talk about the work
that our team has done to try and end
preventable newborn death in sub-saharan
Africa so I'm gonna start by just trying
to put this problem in context for you
and I want to start with the global
target that we have for newborns
survival so with the Millennium
Development Goals we had targets for
child survival but we did not have a
target for newborn survival and we made
a lot of progress to reduce rates of
mortality for children but we made
comparatively little progress to reduce
rates of newborn mortality and as a
result newborn deaths now account for
45% of all childhood deaths but in the
SDG is we have a target for newborn
survival so all countries should get
newborn death rates below 12 per
thousand by 2030 so let's take a look at
what it will take to actually achieve
that target so it's shown on the y-axis
is mortality rate the green is the
childhood mortality rate the blue is the
newborn mortality rate and we have data
and then we have projections and so if
we look at newborns you can see that
there's been less progress for newborns
here's our target right here if we are
going to hit our target we have to
double the rates of progress that we're
making toward this goal and the biggest
gap for the places where acceleration is
most needed or African countries more
than 30 African countries need to double
the rates of progress that they're
making
if they're going to achieve the SDG so
we can look at that projection so again
now we're looking at newborn mortality
versus time so here's this year and if
we look at where will be a current rates
of progress to get to the SDG where
we're supposed to be in 2030 if we don't
accelerate our progress it won't be we
won't be there for Africa until 2060 six
and if we ask the question when will a
baby born in Africa have the same chance
of survival as a baby born and a
high-income country the answer is not
until twenty one twenty four it will be
more than a hundred and ten years before
we achieve equity for newborn survival
and I think the most there are so many
things that are sad about that statistic
but for me the thing that is most
troubling is when we think about the
progress that we made in this country to
improve newborn survival it really
started in the late 1960s early 1970s
when we introduced regional Knick use it
will take African countries three times
as long to make that progress as it did
for us to make that progress in the
United States we have a Tesla and space
and it will take three times as long for
African countries to make that same kind
of progress and I think that's just not
acceptable
given all of the technologies that we
have available to us so let's take a
look at historically what happened in
the US and the UK so again we're looking
at newborn mortality and we're looking
at actual data and the US and the UK so
here's where we were in the 1900s our
newborn mortality was 40 per thousand
that's where most of Western and Central
Africa is today so if we look at the
first phase of reduction there was a 25%
action from 40 to 30 over that 40-year
period from 1900 to 1940 and that was
primarily public health improvement so
sanitation improvements in clean water
that allows you to go from 40 to 30
that's where most of eastern Africa is
today where we were in the 40s if we
want to go the next step of the way to
where we were in the 1970s this is where
South Africa is today that happened by
providing basic hair so warmth improves
feeding improved hydration if we want to
get below 15 and reach the target of 12
we cannot get there without technology
data from every middle-income and
upper-income country that made that
transition to get below the SDG target
did it by making technology available
for comprehensive newborn care and so
what we really need is we really need to
have basic care and comprehensive
newborn care and so what I would like to
talk with you about is the approach that
we have been taking to think about how
as an engineering community can we think
about the need to develop technologies
that can allow countries that are at the
newborn mortality rates of 40 and 30 how
can we make it possible for them to
achieve the STG and I think that's
possible now more than ever before
because of three important shifts that
have happened over the last 15 years the
first important shift is that there has
been a big investment to understand how
many newborns are dying
where are they dying and why are they
dying and this was largely in part
led by investments from the Gates
Foundation and so we really have a very
good understanding to track where
progress is needed but evidence without
political will does not lead to change
now that we have a target for a newborn
survival we have political will and this
is something that's new in the last few
years but finally the third and I think
in some ways most exciting shift is that
the place of birth is moving and it's
moving from home in to health care
facilities 80 percent of women are now
delivering in health care facilities
worldwide and so change is possible as
never before but change is not
inevitable
there was a really interesting article
that was published in the Journal of
Global Health in December of 2017 and
what they did in this paper was they
surveyed health facilities in five
countries and they just looked at
whether or not they had the facilities
to deliver newborn care or maternal care
and whether they had a clinical
workforce that was ready to deliver
maternal care and newborn care and
across all five countries the thing that
scored the most poorly was facility
readiness for newborn care and this is a
quote from the conclusion of that
article that says in all five countries
key services for newborns were missing
from a large proportion of facilities
that offer delivery services and the big
risk is that not just that will provide
poor quality care but if women come to
facilities to have their babies and
they're met by poor quality care and
their babies die we run the very big
risk that they will stop coming to
facilities to have their babies and that
will have a shift in the progress that
we've made to get more women coming to
facilities so I have had the pleasure to
be part of a multi institutional and
multi multi disciplinary
game called nest that has focused on
trying to address this challenge so nest
stands for newborn essential solutions
and technologies and it's a partnership
between Rice University Northwestern
University the London School of Hygiene
and Tropical Medicine the University of
Malawi and five other universities in
Malawi Tanzania and Nigeria and we are
focused on trying to provide the
technologies that are needed for newborn
care in this setting this is Queen
Elizabeth Central Hospital the main
teaching hospital in Malawi and when you
walk through Queen Elizabeth's Central
Hospital you see a lot of equipment that
was designed for high resource settings
that was donated to the facility that
ends up in what we refer to as the
equipment graveyard so here you can see
some oxygen concentrators before we were
looking at a big pile of syringe pumps
this equipment was donated by people who
really wanted to do something positive
but when the equipment encounters the
harsh environmental conditions the heat
the dust the humidity the line voltage
surges and sags it fails and it's really
not able to provide care and what is
needed instead is a set of equipment
that is effective that is affordable and
that is sustainable and that is the kind
of equipment that we our team and a
whole community innovators has been
focused on trying to develop over the
last five to ten years and so when I
first went to Queen Elizabeth Central
Hospital I was taken to the the newborn
intensive care unit and I saw a baby's
like this one this is a little baby his
name is chicken jet so he was born
prematurely
he suffered from respiratory distress
syndrome as about half of babies who are
born prematurely do in the US or another
high resource setting this would easily
be treated with a technology called CPAP
which stands for continuous
airway pressure and it's basically a way
to provide a blended mix of air and
oxygen at constant pressure to reduce
the work of breathing while the baby
begins producing a surfactant that
reduces alveolar surface tension and
then it is able to breathe with less
work of breathing so my my clinical
collaborators explained to me that CPAP
machines cost about $6,000 most of them
require wall air and while oxygen which
were not available at this particular
facility and they were really frustrated
that they did not have access to this
technology so my colleagues and I went
back to Rice University we have a
makerspace very similar to the one that
I got to visit here today and we began
working with our students to think about
developing a low-cost bubble CPAP system
so you just saw queen Dubey there the
pediatrician that we collaborate with
and this is the very first prototype
CPAP system that they developed there
are two aquarium pumps that are inside
this little plastic shoebox and flow
regulators to blend the flow and a
bottle of water to control the end
expiratory pressure and the students
were able to take this device over to
Texas Children's Hospital and compare
the flow and pressure that their device
delivered and they were able to show
that it matched the performance of the
systems that were being used at Texas
Children's Hospital and so one of the
students on the team Jocelyn Brown who
you see here traveled to Malawi as part
of a summer internship and she
demonstrated her CPAP device to all of
the nurses that worked in the newborn
unit and they told her everything that
was wrong with her device they said this
little plastic shoebox it's too flimsy
it's going to break they said some of
the tubes come out the front other tubes
come out the back it's too easy to put
the wrong tube in the wrong port you've
designed it to run on a 110 volt source
that's not the line voltage that we have
here
Malawi but they wanted to keep it and
begin using it to treat their patients
and so Jocelyn took her Tobias she
brought it back to rice and we worked
with a commercial partner to make the
device more rugged more robust to go
through a quality manufacturing process
and then to secure permission from our
IRB and the local IRB to evaluate its
performance and this is what that little
shoebox turned into we call this device
the Palani Kewanee means breathe
restfully into java the local language
and it was chosen by the nurses who gave
Jocelyn the feedback on that first
device so with IRB permission we were
able to evaluate the performance of this
technology and we compared rates of
survival for babies who suffered from
respiratory distress syndrome who were
treated with nasal oxygen at the time
the local standard of care to babies who
were treated with CPAP and we found that
survival improved from 24 percent to 65
percent when they were treated with the
CPAP device we've since partnered with a
company called third stone design who
took the technology through the
regulatory approval process and we got
funding from USAID to begin scaling it
up across Malawi and so we've partnered
with the Ministry of Health to deliver
CPAP to all 28 district hospitals in the
country that are run by the government
as well as the majority of the Mission
District hospitals and we've worked now
with 14 nursing and clinical officer
schools to implement training for CPAP
as part of the pre-service training
curriculum when we first started this
project I thought that when we got to
the end of the scaling we would be done
that that would be the end of this
project and all right we were all wrong
in that assumption because as we
traveled around to these district
hospitals what we found was that babies
were cold
old and there was no technology to
provide warmth babies were dehydrated
there weren't syringe pumps to deliver a
fluid babies had jaundice they didn't
have photo therapy lights and ways to
diagnose jaundice and clinicians were
really really frustrated that they
didn't have the tools that were needed
to help provide comprehensive care for
their patients we came back from that
experience feeling that if we continue
to introduce technology as one at a time
what we would find is that outcomes
would continue to be capped low what we
found in our rollout of CPAP was that
babies who were hypothermic did not do
very well if you only provided CPAP it's
not surprising it's not the approach
that any other middle or low in a middle
or high-income country took in scaling
up care for newborns and so we came back
to the drawing board and we said let's
look at this problem holistically and
let's start with what are the leading
causes of mortality for babies in this
setting and all across the world babies
died of three main causes of death
they're born prematurely they suffer
from an infection or they're injured
during labor and delivery and from these
causes of death we've looked at what are
the pathways of care that clinicians
need to provide to prevent or treat
these causes of death and we identified
seven different pathways of care that
they needed to provide so the baby in
the middle is getting CPAP but we also
need to be able to monitor and treat
jaundice if he suffers from that we need
to do that in a separate neonatal ward
where their babies aren't getting
exposed to infections that are coming in
from the pediatric population they need
to be kept warm they need to we need to
diagnose prevent and treat infections
and so we thought about with all these
pathways of care what technologies are
needed to enable clinicians to provide
those pathways of care and what
surprised me was that the list is not
that long
it's a list of 17 different technologies
that if you had access to the 17 things
you have the ability to provide care
along these pathways and we looked at
what is available commercially that
meets our criteria of effectiveness
affordability and sustainability and
what we found was that for about half of
these technologies for 8 there are
commercially available alternatives that
have been designed specifically to work
in in low resource settings but for 9
there were no commercially available
alternatives and so our team began to
try and develop technologies to address
these needs so for example if you look
at the problem of jaundice there are a
lot of photo therapy lights that are out
there on the market that have been
designed to work in low resource
settings MTTs makes the firefly de rêve
makes brilliance so there's not a neat
little sparrows makes the Billy Hutt
there's not a need we thought for
another appropriate set of photo therapy
lights but there was no commercially
available Billy a Reuben watt serum
bilirubin monitor that we could identify
and so that's a problem that we took on
and began developing and so we've been
working for a number of years to bring
that together and what we did this last
year was we put together the whole set
of 17 technologies and it was really
exciting to see what they all look like
together so this is what we think a
district hospital that has 5000
deliveries per year should be equipped
with so you can see the photo therapy
lights delivery photo therapy here's an
oxygen concentrator and a flow splitter
here you see the CPAP setup with the
concentrator a syringe pump a suction
machine a pulse oximeter
so in incising this for a hospital that
has 5000 deliveries per year
we think that this equipment should have
a lifetime of five years and then it's
really important to minimize the cost of
consumables and if you just work out the
math for how much it costs to provide
this package of technology divided by
the number of deliveries that would be
delivered at a hospital over that five
year period we estimate that this set of
technologies could be delivered for a
dollar 48 per delivery and so I think
the exciting thing is that technology
has the potential to be as affordable as
vaccines which we have been very
effective at scaling up and and this
includes rolled into this as the cost of
distribution as well as the cost of
supplying consumables over that
five-year period so our our team is
working to complete this package of
innovations we are constantly surveying
the landscape of what is commercially
available and as new things become
commercially available adding them into
the package where they make sense
comparing their performance in the field
to look at whether they're sufficiently
rugged and and robust but we also need
to think about the challenge of
distribution so the phototherapy lights
that I mentioned earlier the MTTs lights
are distributed primarily in Vietnam the
Dro of phototherapy lights are
distributed primarily in India and if
you try and order either set of lights
in Africa you're going to pay more in
shipping than you will to pay for the
cost of the lights so the challenge of
distribution in Africa is really
significant for medical technologies we
also simultaneously need to think about
how do we aggregate demand in the public
sector and the private sector because
it's very difficult to solve the
distribution challenge if you haven't
and one of the things that it will take
to aggregate demand and unlock demand
unlock resources in the public sector
especially is good-quality evidence that
this package of technologies can save
lives and then it can do so in a way
that is cost effective we need to really
demonstrate that we can achieve that
dollar 48 number not just estimate that
we can achieve that number and so I want
to walk you through briefly each of
those elements of what our team is doing
together so let me start with where we
are in terms of innovation this is a
picture that was taken at Lagos
University Teaching Hospital so it's one
of the largest teaching hospitals in
Nigeria and you can see that they are
very well equipped with photo therapy
lights so those are the the D Rev lights
that you see being used at Luth but they
don't have a way to measure bilirubin
concentration and so our team came back
and began developing a point-of-care
tool to measure bilirubin and it
consists of a little piece of paper and
plastic there is a membrane here that
you apply a drop of blood from a heel
stick to and then you remove a piece of
paper that exposes adhesive fold it shut
and plasma will flow down to the distal
tip of the device you can see that it
appears white for blood that has a
normal bilirubin level and this is blood
from a baby with an elevated bilirubin
level you can see by eye that it's
yellow you simply insert this little
disposable into the reader that you see
here press the button will shine light
at three different wavelengths through
that piece of paper and report the
bilirubin concentration so we've just
completed and published a pilot study
looking at a clinical assessment of this
compared to a laboratory standard and
you can see here's the bland Altman plot
so we're within plus or minus two
milligrams per deciliter for our
agreement we're very close to
the clea standard with this device and
if we compare that to the performance of
a transcutaneous billy Reuben ometer you
can see this is not from the same
population this was a study done at Luth
and in Nigeria looking at the accuracy
of a transcutaneous billy ray manometer
and you can see there there within minus
2 to plus almost 5 milligrams per
deciliter it's not accurate enough for
that population and if you look at what
would happen to the dollar 48 number if
we replace our ability Reuben ometer
with this device the dollar 48 number
goes over $12 and that increase is
almost exclusive exclusively associated
with the consumables that are needed to
calibrate the transcutaneous bilirubin
ometer so it's sold under a razor razor
blade model which just doesn't work in a
setting where cost is such a big
pressure
similarly delivering fluid to Babies IV
medications or or saline or glucose
solution has to be delivered at
carefully controlled rates and syringe
pumps are a real challenge to keep going
in this environment so we have developed
a very low-cost syringe pump that has a
streamlined user interface that is less
likely to lead to user error because of
the way the the drivetrain is designed
it can run for over 70 hours on a single
battery charge so if the power goes out
as is common in these settings it will
keep delivering fluid this meets IEC
standards for performance for syringe
pumps in the United States and this is
just looking at the accuracy we've
evaluated it both in newborns as well as
in pregnant women who are who have
preeclampsia and are being treated with
magnesium sulfate and in both
populations it meets IEC standards for
performance and then finally I think
this is my favorite technology because
one of the things that
surprised me so much was the invisible
what I think is a medical emergency of
hypothermia there are so many babies who
are dying because they are too cold in
this setting nurses have access to
thermometers but in a setting where
there may be one nurse every 20 babies
it's really difficult for them to have
time to measure temperatures frequently
enough and then they don't necessarily
have access to warmers for babies that
are not stable enough to be receiving
kangaroo mother care so we've designed a
really simple wearable that displays the
temperature and so you can see this baby
was at 35 degrees C that's hypothermic
so there's a blue light on the top they
can easily see just by looking across
the ward if a baby is too cold just
right or has a fever and then intervene
appropriately we use the same sensor to
control a warming crib if the baby does
need to receive additional warming to to
get back to a normal temperature and
this device is completely reusable we
can make it for less than $25 and it's a
really simple technology we've just
completed a pilot study evaluating this
technology and it performed equivalently
to the GE vital signs monitor so how do
we keep things out of the equipment
graveyard all of these technologies are
designed to be rugged but they still
need preventive maintenance and they
still need in some cases reparative
maintenance to address that challenge
we've partnered with local engineering
schools and one of the things that I
think is an amazing opportunity is a lot
of universities in sub-saharan Africa
now are starting biomedical engineering
diploma and degree programs and this is
something that the Ministry of Health
and the Ministry of Education in many
locations are collaborating to do when
you look at
engineering education in this part of
the world it tends to be very
theoretical and students have very few
opportunities to actually do design or
to interact hands-on with equipment in
laboratories and so one of the things
that I'm most excited about is we've
been able to partner with the University
of Malawi and build an engineering
design studio there and so here you see
students who are working in that
engineering design studio they are
developing locally appropriate ways to
repair oxygen concentrators and to
develop spare parts that can be used to
regenerate the compressors and to
regenerate the SIP beds without having
to import expensive replacements and
we're just getting ready to expand this
to another school in Malawi and also the
Darussalam Institute of Technology and I
think that's really what can lead to the
next generation of innovators that can
solve health problems in other parts of
the hospital we've been doing a
bi-directional student exchange now for
the last three years with students from
Malawi coming to Houston students from
rice going to Malawi and participating
in teams to to take on these design
challenges and doing the same thing at
the faculty level we're really excited
to begin to expand that here we go so I
want to talk about the challenge of
distribution because this surprised our
whole team when we really began to
understand how big this challenge was
and what it would take to solve it so as
the poem on a CPAP was developed we
partnered with third stone design and
industrial design firm the very first
generation of the pull money that was
evaluated clinically looked like the
device you see there on the left so it
was in a more rugged enclosure than the
device in the plastic shoebox but it
didn't look like the final product which
has gone
the the CEM our process and so these
devices are now made in the Bay Area by
a manufacturing group called pride
industries they're made a relatively low
volume so over a thousand seep apps have
been sold they've been sold in 30
countries where they're they're being
used and the the CEO of third stone
design has opened up the financials of
the company so they license the
technology from rice and they licensed
it at zero percent royalty and they
guaranteed that they would set their
price within a certain fraction of their
cost of making it and that they would
prioritize filling orders and gobby
eligible countries and so for us and
licensing the technology access was
really the thing that we were most
interested in insuring and so if we look
at the cost to distribute a single
punani device it cost them about five
hundred and fifty dollars to make it
they sell it for eight hundred dollars
and so that leaves you two hundred and
fifty dollars but two hundred fifty
dollars it turns out is not enough to
distribute bomani you've got to ship it
you've got to clear customs you've got
to train users and you've got to provide
service and all of those costs and their
experience add up to seven hundred and
fifty dollars and so every time third
stone ships up Amani out of their
facility basically they're sticking a
five hundred dollar bill on top of it so
I'm not a business person but I know
that this is not a sustainable way to
move forward and that's where I think we
get really excited about the opportunity
to bring together a package of
technologies so just like a one
technology newborn unit can't solve the
problem of improving newborn survival a
one product company cannot be
sustainable without elevating prices to
the point that are not affordable so if
you think about what happens when we're
distributing
package of technologies the cost of
goods is higher we estimate that it will
cost $26,000 to equip that NICU that I
showed you earlier so you've still got
some margin left but the costs of
distribution are not 17 times what they
are for one technology because you can
package them together you can train
people to use them together a service
technician who's making a call for one
piece of equipment can look at the
entire package and so you gain enormous
ability to sustain this in distributing
a package of technologies together and
so our colleagues at third stone are now
working to establish two distribution
hubs and country we're targeting Nigeria
and Tanzania as the initial locations
for those distribution hubs and our team
is focused on targeting a network of
seven countries in Africa that have
partnered with the World Health
Organization and UNICEF to form what's
called the quality equity dignity
Network these countries have committed
to cutting newborn deaths in half within
four years and these seven countries
together represent 46% of births on the
continent and so our hope is that in
targeting these seven countries that
account for almost half the births on
the continent we can get to a tipping
point that will support their their
dissemination much more broadly
throughout the continent we've done
projections for what we think it will
take to make this distribution
organization sustainable and we think it
will take philanthropic investment so
the little white bars here represent
philanthropic investment sales revenues
and then costs and we think within a six
year period it can get to sustainability
and it's based on the actual data of
distributing the the pramanya CPAP
so one of the things that we're really
excited about is the opportunity to
begin to partner with social impact
investors to think about how to target
not just facilities that are public
facilities but to think about how to
target private hospitals in a country
like Malawi almost all of the healthcare
is provided by either government
hospitals or the the faith-based mission
hospitals and so although they're
private it's not the same as a place
like Nigeria for example where more than
half of care in the country is provided
through private for-profit hospitals
that are serving not just wealthy
Nigerians but a broad spectrum of
patients of different income levels so
one of the most exciting things for us
over the last two years is when we learn
about an organization called the medical
credit Fund with a medical credit fund
does is it partners with private
hospitals and it offers them loans well
it doesn't offer them loans it
guarantees loans for them to invest in
capital equipment to improve their
services so they have provided over 13
1,500 loans they work with local banks
so they have 14 local banking partners
that they work with so the banks provide
the loans the medical credit fund
guarantees the loan so they help
hospitals that don't have a credit
history or collateral get ready to go to
the bank they have dispersed over 30
million dollars over the last five years
any guesses as to what their default
rate is
would you believe 3% it's amazing and
we're really excited because the average
loan size is about $20,000 so it's very
comparable to what we project will be
the cost of the nest package and so
we're partnering with the medical credit
Fund to use some of our resources to
play around with the credit terms
because it might be that if you were
willing to target a 5 percent default
rate you might be able to make twice as
many loans medical credit fund knows
right now that they're turning away a
lot of good credit risks but their
investors are not very risk tolerant and
so I think it's a really exciting
opportunity to see how can technology
developers partner with impact investors
to help get their technologies to scale
so finally I want to talk about the the
data that's needed to get to aggregate
demand on the the public sector side so
here what we're doing is we're
partnering with our colleagues at the
London School of Hygiene and Tropical
Medicine and we're beginning to roll out
nest in Malawi we've started with the 8
technologies that are commercially
available and in Malawi what we're doing
is we're evaluating what are the things
that are barriers to scale what are the
conditions that are necessary to get to
scale and using that to develop a theory
of change we will then move to Tanzania
where it will implement a step wedge
trial in southern Tanzania where the
newborn mortality rate is over 40 and
we'll look at what is the impact what
are the cost and what is the
cost-effectiveness of rolling out this
package of technologies to support
comprehensive newborn care and then
we'll work in Nigeria to evaluate this
market-based model of financing
technologies for private sector
facilities we're working as part of the
quality of care network and I think this
is really an amazing opportunity because
these are countries that are committed
to the same goal
we are which is to reduce the deaths of
newborns and hospital facilities 2030 is
only 12 years away we know that you
can't get to 12 without having
technology available no country has been
able to do that and so if we're going to
do it
people need these things yesterday if
they're going to have a chance to make
an impact I think without access to
technologies that make comprehensive
newborn care available we're stuck in
the situation where it will be over a
hundred years before babies in Africa
catch up to all of the benefits that
babies who are born in high-income
countries have benefited from and over a
million babies will continue to die
really unnecessarily in Africa alone so
we think by making this package
available we have the potential to
reduce by half death rates in the next
decade and do it at a cost that has been
acceptable for scaling up vaccines which
have had enormous impact on reducing
childhood death I am part of a much
larger team that includes my colleagues
in Malawi and my colleagues in Tanzania
in Nigeria in Chicago and in London and
it's just been such a pleasure to work
with this amazing group of people and I
want to end with this picture which is
probably my favorite picture in the
whole world this is chicken jutsu and
I've used the little baby that you saw
in the video at the beginning who was
struggling to breathe and this picture
was taken he was just over two years old
when this picture was taken his name
means the Conqueror and our hope is to
enable hundreds of thousands of babies
like chicken jet so to conquer the
challenges that they face right now and
just surviving the first day of life the
first week of life and
make many many more photos like this
possible let me stop there I'm happy to
take any questions thank you
[Applause]
your phones on each side if anybody has
a question please raise your hand thank
you very much oh sorry thanks for
sharing all that wonderful work I wonder
if you could talk a little bit more
specifically about how these innovations
have worked in practice the development
of the innovations have worked in
practice so what are the roles of
students faculty is this around classes
or how have you put it in practice yeah
so what we what we do now is we do a lot
of shadowing of clinicians nurses
clinical officers physicians and really
try and understand what are the barriers
they face and delivering care and then
turn those into design challenges that
will bring two teams of students
sometimes they'll come up with something
that looks promising other times it's
just a good learning opportunity for the
students where they come up with a
prototype that looks promising we will
work with students who are interested in
continuing it as part of an independent
study where that makes sense where we'll
maybe move it up from a freshman to a
capstone design team we have really made
use of post baccalaureate fellowships to
take things from a promising prototype
to something that you can actually get
into clinical evaluation so these are
typically students who are coming in
recent with a recent bachelor's degree
or master's degree and who will spend
usually two years really focusing on
moving that forward sometimes we'll move
some of the projects up out to where a
PhD student is taking it forward so the
Billy Rubin work that I presented
actually started with a sophomore design
team moved into a capstone design team
and then there was a PhD student that
really took it across the finish line
the syringe pump was an example where it
went through to senior design teams
we really sort of got it right and then
there was a post-baccalaureate fellow
who's taken it to where it is now and so
we've got this sort of continuum of
students and staff who are engaged at
various points along the way there's a
very close communication between our
clinical collaborators so we do regular
design reviews to make sure that you
know we don't fall in love with our
technology and end up developing
something that they don't really want
like on the the temperature monitor what
I told the students was don't waste your
money on a digital display you know I
just want a blue light a green light and
a red light and what the nurses said was
whoa we app we absolutely want that
digital display because every four hours
we have to record the temperature and it
will save us so much time if you include
that and at first like I didn't believe
the students so I had asked the nurses
and it was definitely where the feedback
was coming from so you know we tried a
really a guard against biases like that
so they don't and loadshedding is a huge
challenge in this environment the
approach that we're taking is to look at
providing solar backup power together
with the suite of instruments because
it's really difficult to power some of
the devices with battery backup like the
oxygen concentrators for example and the
radiant warmers are the two things that
are the most power hungry
we've tried wherever possible to include
battery backup so the syringe pump has
it the warming current that we've
developed was specially designed to
retain heat but we're exploring solar
backup as a way to power things like the
concentrator and the radiant warmer
counties or maybe cities in this country
that would benefit from implementation
of some of these devices so I think I
think that answer is really device
specific so I think potentially the
Billy Reuben device for example we've
had pediatricians here express a lot of
interest and having access to something
like that we've had interest in the CPAP
as a transport device so for a baby
that's getting transferred from a
community setting to a higher level of
care right now they're providing support
by hand and so this is something that
could easily be used for transport you
know I think when we're designing them
we really think about what is the right
set of features to meet the needs of our
target hospitals and we're we're not so
much taking the approach of can we come
up with something that can work in both
types of settings so it's when there are
opportunities we're really interested in
exploring them thank you for the talk um
some of these technologies seem like
they utilize technologies that are not
so exotic and I'm wondering what the
reason for current devices being so
expensive or what are the primary
reasons that current devices are so
expensive that are unaffordable while
you can make one that is a fraction of
the price so you know I think there's
there's two reasons for that difference
so one is we've really thought about
what is the minimum set of features that
is necessary in an environment where
basically when you look at viability for
babies in this setting babies who weigh
less than a thousand grams really don't
survive in this setting and that's very
different than in
q in the United States where you're
taking care of 500 grand babies who are
going to survive and so I think because
the population of baby is that we're
looking at are bigger in terms of weight
and they're usually further along in
terms of gestational age so there's
they're way too small for their
gestational age there are some features
that would be necessary in a setting
where you're taking care of really tiny
tiny babies that you that are not the
first thing that you would want to put
in in this setting so that's one reason
I think another reason is there's no
question that one model of profitability
for a medical device manufacturing in
this country is we're not going to make
money on the hardware but we're going to
make a lot of money on the consumables
and that has been really challenging and
this setting or distribution is such a
problem and so I can't tell you how many
devices I have seen that get to the
setting they're used until the
consumables that came with the device
run out and then it ends up in the
equipment graveyard
about the equipment graveyard what are
some common ways that the engineering
students in Africa create their own
spare parts for these machines I'm not
sure I understood your question it was
it what what spare parts are they making
for their own machines yes what are they
making to repair these devices so what
the oxygen concentrators in particular
it was really interesting to look at
what was happening so I originally
thought that they were failing because
of line voltage surges which were
killing the electronics and that turned
out to be the case and maybe 15 20
percent of the cases but the much more
common case was that dust in the
environment was going through the case
filter so the case filter is just really
inappropriate for dusty environments we
did in a little experiment where we took
the case filters out we swept up dust in
the NICU and we looked at what fraction
of the dust was trapped by the filter
and it was less than 1% not very
effective that dust gets in the
compressors it causes the seals to fail
as the compressors start to fail then
the SIP beds start to fail and so
they're replacing the cup seals and the
compressors and then they're
regenerating the SIP as I'm using some
really innovative approaches like - that
could give you a small token of our
appreciation you'll find a few yellow
gifts in there and a ceremonial envelope
that reminds you that the honorarium
which is provided by the silliman
endowment of five thousand dollars will
be forthcoming as soon as you return
from africa she is leaving actually
tomorrow evening after she finishes her
visit here with us to head to africa in
closing if i may i'd like to thank a few
people first Joe Howard who is the chair
of the silliman lecture selection
committee and and the remaining members
of the committee Mitzi Campbell from
biomedical engineering
Steve derringer and Bill we're from the
School of Engineering Applied Science
who did most of the work in organizing
this event and I'd like to thank the
student chapter of our biomedical
engineering society as well as our
graduate students for participating and
helping and finally I'd like to thank
everyone for coming and I would also
like to invite you if you will tomorrow
morning at 10 a.m. as part of the
tradition of the silliman lecture it's
really lectures and tomorrow at 10 a.m.
professor Richards quartum will give us
a seminar in biomedical engineering that
will dress some of the more technical
issues of her work that will be held at
the man Engineering Center which is at
10 hill house room 107 so thank you all
very much and professor Richards quartum
thank you for a wonderful lecture
[Applause]
[Music]